i was watching that comedy store uh
documentary
the other day and uh on showtime
and uh there are parts of it that are
well done and then there are parts of it
where you go
huh i rem so they the episode i watched
last night they get whitney rogan burr
leno annie letterman and they all
take covet tests they all have masks on
and they have
they take covet tests and then they sit
down and mike binder who did the
documentary by the way it's like about
him
think about him what's going on
he's like it's mostly about my journey
with splashes of kinis in here and there
a
little
prior but more me
they're all sitting outside and i and
i'm not bitter that i'm not in it i've
seen it now now i'm like
kind of like that i'm not in it but i
got passed at the comp don't be nervous
i got passive to comedy i don't care if
i ever do this again for a living
i truly don't i truly truly don't uh i
truly don't
i um i was passed at the comedy store
about um which i love i love the store
uh i was passed like a few weeks after
this happened
you know after the whole thing was shot
with the majority of it but they shot a
scene where everybody gets coveted
tested
and so apparently it's in the midst of a
pandemic
and then mike binder looks at everybody
and goes what's going on with pc
culture
and i'm like what in the [ __ ] are you
talking about
the biggest event a seismic
event an asteroid that hit
live performance harder than anything
this guy's going
what do you think about pc culture and
then there's comedians
by the way everyone in that documentary
is like 75.
i got to be honest i got to be honest
you start looking around you're going i
don't know it doesn't feel that
hot stand up don't feel that hot
right now it's like it's all like
elderly people telling you
well when i was a youth richard
it's like it's not it and i love
stand-up and i love doing it and i'll
keep doing it
but part of the reason why i like it is
it is a dead art
okay and and and that documentary
i mean christ
it's just it's a museum it's a mausoleum
in there i mean it's a mausoleum
i mean i was watching with a friend
who's a fan of everybody and they're
like
here's the question i love comedy and
comics are more talented
inherently than tick-tock people but is
the documentary about the tick-tock kids
more interesting
yes is and i like that you didn't
hesitate
it's a documentary about the kids on
tick-tock more interesting
than somebody being like it's just a
joke
[Laughter]
no one cares about pc look guys it's not
even real
i had candace on nobody's people were
mad at me but nobody's trying to cancel
me it doesn't it's over
no one cares and it's still like this
narrative that people keep bringing up
it makes stand-ups look
weak you look weak when you
whine just say it and step
back when i was fighting with people on
twitter
about the candace owens thing i was
fighting because i had a point
i had a point and they had a point they
whatever their point was whatever my
point was
but i don't care that you're mad i knew
you were gonna be mad when we had her on
the show
that's part of the fun
you see i'm not bringing on a history
teacher
who no one knows or cares about i'm
bringing on a woman who's gonna ruffle a
few feathers
i get so this whining week piece it's
just got
it's every podcast has been about this
and only this
so i watched that for a few minutes and
then i had to turn that off
the joke you got jay leno up there be
like
it's a duck what are we doing
what's going on here who cares i don't
care
enough with the legends enough with the
don't you want to kill these people
do these people die do they ever go away
have these [ __ ] have not been
funny in forever
forever and we all have to sit there
like they're [ __ ] christ they climb
down off the cross and we got to watch
their feet
and annoy it's enough is enough already
and i respect them
and uh you know i respect i respect the
the roads they paved so that i may have
to drive
down them but we got to be funny here
doesn't everyone remember that we got to
be a little
funny we can't just sit around on
a trillion dollars they should make
chairs made of money
when they ask these people to pay they
should have to sit in a chair
of money and go
they just have to take the money out of
their bank
and make a couch of it and we're making
money we're not [ __ ] on people that
make money
but it's like it's a pandemic there's
all this [ __ ] to talk about nobody cares
about pc culture
nobody gives a [ __ ] enough pipe down